[Musique]
alors je suis gildo braz j'ai grandi à
la réunion jusqu'à l'âge de
17 ans à peu près et ensuite j'ai quitté
pour aller faire mes études supérieures
à aix en provence et en fait j'ai 30 ans
d'expérience en informatique en gestion
des systèmes d'information j'ai quitté
la provence au bout d'une douzaine
d'années pour aller en nouvelle
calédonie c'est là que j'ai fait
connaissance avec la mer et avec les
fonds marins les que j'en suis tombé
amoureux je suis revenu à la réunion
pour finalement au bout de dix ans
quitter la structure dans laquelle
j'étais est passé du statut de salarié à
celui d'entrepreneur
quant à steak c'est la contraction on va
dire de la qantas terre qui est une
étoile de mer assez impressionnante qui
mange le corail et tex et la technologie
des drones
je suis parti dans cette croisade si on
peut dire un peu contre cette étoile de
mer en utilisant des drones du marché
pour essayer de vendre un service de
surveillance d'exploration du récif
corallien et de nettoyage quand
nécessaire de déprédateurs au sens là
donc l'idée n'est pas que le drone
lui-même mais c'est tous les équipements
que l'on va pouvoir monter dessus pour
de la vidéo pour l'analyse de la qualité
de l'eau pu filmer les la faune maritime
et avoir derrière un traitement des
données qui vont donner de la valeur aux
observations que là que l'on va pouvoir
faire
je suis dans une phase de démarrage je
construis mon savoir-faire donc via
l'aquarium qui est un environnement
privilégié vous faire un certain nombre
de tests et auprès d'acteurs locaux
comme la réserve marine comme les
universités de la réunion pour essayer
de percevoir le besoin le but est
d'arriver ensuite à exporter ce savoir
faire progressivement acquis et de le
vendre
là où il ya des besoins aux
gestionnaires de réserves marines au
ministère de l'environnement avec
l'aquarium montrent un autre projet de
permettre aux visiteurs de s'immerger
dans les bassins via les drones et via
des casques de réalité virtuelle mais
qui projette une vraie réalité celle
filmée par la caméra en temps réel alors
comme dirait cousteau on aime ce qui
nous a émerveillés et on protège ce que
l'on aime
[Musique]
donc laurence 41 ans maman de deux
enfants et saint pierroise
je suis resté sans emploi pendant deux
ans tu as les deux ans qui m'ont servi
en fait à trouver les solutions
techniques financières pour créer cette
entreprise de pressage de disques
vinyles j'avais envie de devenir propre
chef dans un métier de l'artisanat qui a
lié aussi ma passion pour la musique
la première étape ça a été de rencontrer
les professionnels de la fabrication de
disques vinyles en france et en europe
d'étudier la faisabilité en fait d'un
tel projet ici à l'autre bout du monde
pour ça on n'a pas cherché des
financements on a vendu notre maison
s'est adressée
aux banques et outils
à la région et à l'europe à travers les
financements fédère ça allie à la fois
une qualité de son camp ne retrouve pas
forcément numérique et des objets
visuels artistique sur sur la pochette
et ça on retrouvait pas non plus
ailleurs compte tenu de la richesse
musicale de cette région
c'était essentiel de créer une telle
entreprise
la distance a fait douze ans que le
marché du disque vinyle à augmente au
niveau international ça s'est confirmé
cette année parce que il a dépassé le
marché du cd que c'est un outil de
promotion est essentielle pour les pour
les artistes
mon entreprise a fonctionné parce que
elle est la seule dans cette région du
monde permettant de
créer des disques vinyles sur un marché
qui augmente d'année en année c'est
qu'elle va permettre le rayonnement de
à l'international de l'île de la réunion
sur un secteur en pleine expansion en
art est une bonne idée santé vaut mieux
qu'une mauvaise réaliser une finale à la
villa du département à départager ses
candidats
l'entreprise run run riz cordes remporte
ainsi la catégorie start up avec
florence boyle
[Musique]